[Music]
foreign
contributing to the farmers for clinical
trial reporting in R that's the title of
the workshop I have the pleasure to
teach at this year's positive con
alongside Christina Fulmer from GSK and
Pablo rootsky over at rush and here's
the top three reasons why you should
sign up for this Workshop reason number
one open source is really where all the
Innovation as it relates to clinical
trial reporting is happening but for the
past decades the industry has
exclusively relied on Commercial
software to report their clinical trials
over the past five years or so this has
really dramatically changed and
companies a lot of big Pharma companies
small biotechs are all now moving
towards using open source tools and in
particular are for their clinical trial
reporting and the farmer versus truly
where all of this Innovation gets
integrated and you will find a lot of
very thoughtfully designed well-written
R packages for different aspects of
clinical trial reporting so if you want
to be at The Cutting Edge of the open
source development as it relates to
clinical trial reporting this is a
workshop you must attend
number two shiny
while again in the past we have almost
exclusively relied on static
deliverables such as tables listings and
graphs for all final clinical study
reports this has been changing in recent
years as well and people increasingly
leverage
um dashboard Solutions interactive and
data exploration apps for their clinical
trial reporting not only internally from
our exploratory purposes but recently
also for the regular Source set of
things in fact there has been a pilot
submission to the US FDA of a shiny App
instead of the more traditional PDF
based static listings tables and figures
we are teaching you how to use a
particular shiny framework called teal
where you can learn how to create such
an app by yourself and I think you will
really really enjoy this experience
and finally number three which is you
will not only learn how you can leverage
these tools but how you can actually
actively contribute to them such that
you can make the tools even better than
they already are if you see something
and you think like hey we could change
this up to make it even better doing XYZ
we will teach you exactly the steps you
need to follow from things like creating
issues on GitHub how you can create a
feature Branch so on and so forth but
also very importantly how you can
contribute if you don't actually want to
write our code there's a lot of working
groups within the farmer birds with
different packages tackling things like
how should we handle lab data as it
relates to our atom data sets
and you can come in there contribute
your expertise and that way ensure that
what is already in my opinion a very
very robust set of packages becomes even
better more usable for your day-to-day
clinical trial reporting work and with
that being said I'm really really
looking forward to seeing you in Chicago
have a great rest of your day cheers
[Music]